Mishra a draw for you but this was an
absolutely Wild game you had no idea
what's going to happen in the other
games before the round started how did
you approach today's game well today's
game I just wanted to have a fight okay
just play normal game whatever happens
will happen if I lose okay fine if I win
great just just play a normal game and
he came up with some blazing heart
preparation it felt like out of the
opening this F4 followed by this F5 in
fact I think this is novelty and he
played a game previously with castle
castle Knight D5 remember that's right
that's right so you were aware of this
you prepared this as well tell us a bit
about this position what was your
preparation looking like yeah this if I
move I didn't exactly know the main idea
is the is the fight over the D5 Square
and here I basically had two kinds of
moves night before nt5 yes because the
issue is if you play a move like B5
which is quite thematic
the issue is at some point like maybe
okay even here engine says why like
white is close to equal but I was
worried about let's say what I can just
go Knight D5 95 first okay and now like
if I play Knight takes D5 he takes D5
it's the structure didn't look too good
for me but maybe I can go Knight ba D7
F6 maybe somehow I can make this work
but I was worried about the structure
like if like Knight B4 fails division
before correct yes and I have the stock
and he has this sort of bind the another
idea I had was like D5 here this also
look kind of decent but the issue was
like say one idea of this is like e
takes D5 now if Knight takes D5 you go
like even Bishop E4
like this oh sorry this should be four
friendly it doesn't work but some
structure like even if yeah Castle yeah
probably Castle an ic3 bc3 yeah the
structure of white gets the bishop on e4
is actually quite unpleasant because
like Bishop on C cannot get out in B5
counter play yeah yes so you chose this
move right to B4 and transition into
this yeah I think H3 is an accurate like
very it's very inaccurate very bad
because the issue is you I think you
basically have to go G5 here
yes and the reason why I played Bishop
D7 no B5 is like okay generally in the
structure you go B5 Bishop B7 but I was
I was thinking that maybe in some
variations I can go long Castle so I
thought maybe I should just keep the
phone on B7 keep it safe like that yes
here my idea was like say H6 G5 Bishop
takes G5 I don't think engine thinks
this is a great idea but my idea is
Knight G4 Knight G4 yes yes very
interesting and now okay Bishop takes E7
Queen takes E7 somewhere I can even just
give up to G7 pawn and go long castle
for example a queen G3 I go Knight like
Queen H4 it can also exist but like we
G3 I can go Knight F6 Queen G7 long
Castle I go Rook G8 Bishop C6 D5 and I
think we were you guys were looking uh
Yasser and kashka were looking at this
type of positions and he played the move
H3 and yeah I think this bishop Bishop
this A4 move is actually quite nice like
it has to play yeah right if he doesn't
find it I think it's like just like
basically lost on the spot right and
this was the big moment right here when
you decided to take on G4
um perhaps not the best best way but
then he played this move F6
yeah so
we saw you watching the clock uh a
little bit in a panic mode were you
panicking at all or
at first I wanted to play Bishop B5 I
felt like this has like resides yes but
the variation is actually quite great so
C4 Bishop takes C4 yes the first thing I
I saw that was that rukichi King D7 Rook
takes d8
Bishop takes d8 now uh let's say queen
takes
Queen takes E4
Rook takes C4 F takes G7 and now Rook
takes G4 and blackwoods correct so I saw
this variation I thought like okay maybe
black is winning here but then I
realized that actually here I think it's
actually not currently Rook takes d8
because black and blue King takes DNA
and he's still like
probably still winning actually but the
issue with this is actually rookies
correct he forces The Rook to C5 then he
takes on d8 on the fifth right the ship
takes dnf takes G7 enough on Queens no
more taking on C4 no more Rook G4 yeah
this was a nice variation and you
started calculating that you spotted the
depleted I thought and now this is
actually just this should be winning for
black but the issue is apparently the
engine doesn't like the screen F6 move
but I was considering keeping the queen
on C7 but I was worried that in some
cases black white can go like Rook H7
Bishop H6
like apparently it works out tactically
but during the game it's even very scary
to keep the queen away from the King
once you play Queen G6 I'll be Mario uh
you must know that this is probably
going to end in a draw yeah you can't I
did this variation I thought okay this
was working for me but I miscalculated
like in the end this queen D7 oh so all
the way towards you yeah because this is
all first because if Queen G6 Works
actually let's go back to the position
for
but like Queen Queen E4 position
so here I had a choice whether I go
Bishop takes B3 Bishop D7 Queen G6 or
basically any of these
all these three moves
the first thing I wanted to play was
like Bishop takes b3c takes B3 Queen G6
yes but I was worried that okay Queen
takes G6 F takes G6 like this end game
is um apply a pawn but just looking it's
even very very difficult to convert
probably yes I thought it would probably
be a draw so and another like that I
didn't want to give up my Bishop I
thought if I can get the same end game
with Queen without trading on B3 I
should just be completely winning yeah I
had another idea instead of Bishop D7 I
was considering B5 also
it looks ridiculous with the idea of
like Rook C4
yes but I was worried that somewhere
like
maybe like say G5 for example
this is not like totally accurate but
Queen G
but here neither one he has B4 okay so
maybe
four but maybe even B5 Knight A1
directly but Knight A1 yeah Knight A1
now the issue is if I go Rook C4 I just
kind of lose a piece
is somehow good for black but this
yeah I mean you can going from B time to
B4 I didn't see how it kind of helped me
as such it doesn't make a lot of
practical sense yeah so then you decided
did you look at the other games at this
point no no I had like 14 minutes I
spent eight minutes I thought this was
working because the issue is if I go
Bishop D7 like Bishop D7 also looked
like a normal move but I was worried the
white gets counter played by the means
of 95 yes and Knight comes to C6 and now
okay game is already
I have a bishop pair but it's still very
it's here like white is definitely in
the game oh yeah absolutely things get
complicated in this one and you decide
to go with Queen G6 I saw some nice
variations here like okay Queen x86 is
definitely the move you have to play but
for example like Queen A2 I could if
someone doesn't see this this queen D7
draw you could think that King E1 maybe
this somehow holds like Queen E4 Rook H3
but instead of Queen E4 I think Rook C3
is just resigns oh very nice okay it's
not very relevant but okay v92 doesn't
work well I mean it seems like
everything is looking like it's working
out in your favor in this one Arthur not
looking good for him in this one uh what
about Brandon this was yeah big one
right you must have felt those last few
moves when he had only moves your heart
must be racing I wasn't really watching
this game I was walking outside but yeah
this looks this still looks very very
possible to mess this up double edge
yeah very double-edged like rookie A3
King G2 okay just first thing is okay F4
Rook takes E7 you shouldn't blunder well
you can yeah you can at least go Rotator
okay
yeah it should be a draw don't do F4
yeah yeah don't do F4 it takes this hour
um yeah well I'll be Mario we'll let you
go we'll let you go uh watch the final
moments of those two last games and uh
well we're not gonna congratulate you
for anything right now maybe we'll talk
yeah this isn't how I would want to win
the tournament yeah it's this game I
should have found some way to make this
work
guys any questions maybe just a very
quick question ABI menu I mean very
interesting game
um in the last moment you decided to go
King f8 to just repeat but you were
looking at this move King F6 uh which is
very dangerous and we weren't sure if
you are going to play how what were you
thinking in that moment and why did you
not play that yeah instead of King F6
was actually what I was playing to play
at the start but like when I was
calculating this variation from Queen G6
but the issue here is Queen D7
and now actually originally I was
considering Queen H7 but then I realized
Queen d6's main one so this guy this
queen takes D6 is very big issue so
Queen G2 checkers probably the only
move King D1
Rook takes D2
Bishop takes D2 Queen takes D5 I think I
might have seen this far from beginning
but I kind of missed that White House
like in the worst case scenario where I
can go Queen d8 check
King G6
check on G5
King H7 Queen H4 check and just
perpetual
and also other than this maybe white has
some other moves then my king is still a
bit weak so I just I thought okay if
white has minimum trolls make a draw and
go back before something bad happens
yeah I was thinking maybe if it was
around three you would go for some risk
you can get six but now it's maybe not
the time to take risk as this may be an
important draw for the championship so
congratulations really nice game thank
you absolutely yes we're gonna just take
a quick break as we keep an eye